tonight health leaders are trying to
figure out why and what to do about it
joe mohler joining us live from the
convention center a mega second dose
vaccination site
with some of the reasons people are
missing joe
well as many of you know this is one of
two mega vaccination sites today we
learned that more than a quarter of
people who make their appointments for
their second dose here are not showing
up
we have noticed about a 36 percent
no-show rate in individuals receiving
their second dose
people are showing up to get their first
vaccine shot but not their second
we're not sure why that is the case
misty robinson with the southern nevada
health district brought this
issue forward during a statewide coping
19 mitigation meeting thursday
it might be a hesitancy issue or people
might be appointment shopping and
scheduling appointments in
in multiple places they believe some may
be getting the second dose from a
pharmacy and not canceling their
appointment
earlier this month long lines left many
people frustrated with the process but
that has cleared up we're working to
provide
additional public information to
encourage people to get their second
dose
so far in clark county there have been
372 thousand vaccines administered 103
000 of those have been second doses
this week the one shot johnson and
johnson vaccine is being reviewed by the
fda
that will be easier from a republic who
want to get the vaccine but don't
necessarily
want to come back twice state officials
say the vaccine review process won't
take long
if we go by what's happened previously
with the other two products we could see
the the johnson johnson product in the
next week or so
and this week the southern nevada health
district is playing catch-up after that
delay in shipment last week they're
expected to administer around 30 000
second
doses and they are asking if you are if
you do have an appointment and you do
not plan to go
to cancel that appointment by calling
reporting live here at the convention
center this evening joe muller 8 news
now